[Music]
do you want to have kids
if so when and how many
it's a big decision
there may be small bundles of Joy but
they can cost a fortune
as people weigh up the pros and cons of
procreating fewer children are being
born especially in the rich world
and in the long term this can mean fewer
young workers to support the elderly so
is it worth having kids
[Music]
I went back and forth a lot in the
beginning yeah good job buddy a lot of
thought that went into weighing the
options of both having kids and not
having kids
Jessica and her husband Andre live in
Houston Texas with their two-year-old
son Michael
[Music]
the day he was born I was overcome with
a lot of emotion happiness just Joy it's
crazy
everywhere
so having children makes people happy
right
in the short term yes but in the long
term not necessarily
according to academics it's likely
Jessica was experiencing what's known as
a happiness month
mother's happiness levels rise in the
Years leading up to giving birth
but that's where they Peak
and within a few years a return to the
level they were before the kid was born
we've been studying men and women in
couples with and without children and we
see that their levels of happiness and
life satisfaction mental health the
Wilderness are quite similar that's
quite consistent across a lot of
different countries
some factors do affect people's
happiness such as their income and
whether they are single parents
parents in countries with stronger
welfare systems also report higher
levels of happiness but all in all there
isn't much difference between the life
satisfaction of parents and people
without kids
while there might be moments during the
day that are filled with happiness the
more typical experience is that being
together with your children can be quite
distressful it also takes up much of
your time and energy it brings with it a
lot of worries
a downward facing dog together ready
I thought motherhood would be you know
you see all the stuff in the movies I
really thought that it would be this
beautiful time where you'd have a great
relationship with your kids
but also you know a little bit of hard
work too that I don't think I understood
before we decided to have Michael
about 80 percent of parents in America
say parenting is enjoyable
but almost 30 percent also are met it's
stressful all or most of the time
[Music]
it won't make you happy why have them
for most of history people had lots of
children which made Financial sense
because kids could work in the fields
and look after their parents in old age
but as societies have grown Richer there
has been a reduction in procreation
we've seen a change in why people have
children and the economic incentives to
having children so as we have more
countries offering pensions older adults
are unless reliant on their adult
children to provide for them in their
older years and at the same time we see
more women getting higher levels of
Education being employed we also see a
change in attitudes a move towards
secularization so less importance of
religion a rise in feminism a rise in
women's rights and childhood extends
because we need to educate our children
longer so the costs of raising children
go up
oh
and kids can be costly
the costs start even before birth
fertility treatment for those who need
it is expensive
and in some countries giving birth in a
hospital can cost thousands of dollars
then there's food clothes nappies toys
baby carriers and prams
The Economist has calculated that a
typical American family can expect to
spend almost three hundred thousand
dollars raising a child to the age of
17.
factor in college tuition and it rises
to over four hundred thousand dollars
for Jessica and Andre in Houston those
costs are about to go up even more
they're expecting their second child
[Music]
oh no let's not touch that the financial
implications are big children are
expensive
I mean there is less stuff to buy you
know just because we already have you
know a car seat and all that stuff from
Michael we are saving for education and
all that stuff for our two kids instead
of one The Strain on Jessica's and
Andre's budget is not helped by the fact
that America is the only rich country
that doesn't have nationwide statutory
paid parental leave instead federal
policy is just 12 weeks of unpaid leave
but there are so many restrictions only
56 of workers are eligible and many feel
they can't afford to sacrifice their
salary for this long at the time when
Michael was born I was the primary
Breadwinner for our family I did not get
paid maternity leave that definitely
played a role in terms of deciding how
long of a maternity leave to take and
after two months I went back to work
full time
it was definitely hard leaving Michael
after two months just because that's
around the time when kids start to
become a little bit more interactive
babies start to smile so I almost felt
like I was missing out on something by
going back to work so soon
statutory parental leave in rich
countries varies greatly
in Japan parents are given about a year
of paid parental leave Each of which
half is paid at about two-thirds of
their normal salary
in Finland parents are given about 14
months of paid leave to share
they're also entitled to take further
Child Care leave up until their child is
three
in Britain a mother's job is guaranteed
for a year but only six weeks are paid
at almost full salary a further 33 weeks
are paid but at a much lower level
it means Britain has one of the least
generous leave policies in Europe which
can make it harder for some Brits to
balance their budgets what do you like
mixing into pancakes
Faye lives in the south of England with
her husband Matt and their
three-year-old daughter Eloise where the
last one trying to do it with me yeah
I took 12 months maternity leave so the
last three months of maternity leave
were unpaid unfortunately and but it was
something that we sat down and worked
out that we could achieve financially
with my husband doing extra overtime
even before those final three months
there isn't a huge amount of pay for
maternity leave we just had to be
financially very conscious of what we
were spending
yeah you can still find all the edge
bits first can't you and those
challenges don't end when the parent
goes back to work
when we were looking at our finances we
didn't really factor in Nursery costs
when we then looked at child care costs
it was huge and some months she was
going two days a week and some months it
was more than our mortgage the costs are
sometimes crippling
in six oecd countries couples earning
the average wage spend over 20 percent
of their salaries on child care
is that honey Britain has the joint's
second most expensive child care in the
world
we have thought about having another
child
unfortunately the cost side of things
does have a big impact I could give up
work but I don't want to rely on
benefits or income support we want to be
self-sufficient if that means not having
another child
because of the financial implications
It's upsetting because we would love to
have another one
it's not just in Britain
a survey of young American adults found
that of those who said they have or
expect to have fewer children than
they'd like 64 cited child care costs as
a reason
hi I'm Anna and I directed this film if
you're enjoying watching it you might be
interested to know that Economist
subscribers get access to a wealth of
global analysis on every conceivable
topic you can read it you can listen to
it you can even be part of it at live
webinars for the best deal on a
subscription click on the link and now
on with the film
it's not just the direct course having
kids can also affect how much mothers
earn
most parents experience a loss in
take-home pay when they take parental
leave men in heterosexual relationships
experience a very small short-term dip
but for women the dip is much bigger and
their earnings rarely recover
this is known as the motherhood penalty
[Music]
Jolie brilli is the founder of the
British charity pregnant then screwed
the motherhood penalty is the pay
differential between mothers and other
types of employees it's essentially a
procreation pay Gap when you have a baby
the way that a parental leave system
functions it encourages women to take
long periods of time out of the
workforce it doesn't encourage men to do
the same
in most sexual couples the father will
earn the most money so when women look
to return to work they look at the cost
of child care and they compare it to
their own salary and in most cases it
doesn't add up they then start to make
career sacrifices they look to return
part-time if at all or they change jobs
to something that's more suitable so
that they can continue to do the Lion's
Share of the caring and the unpaid labor
and so all of this starts to hack away
at their income and their career
progression
in Britain mothers are three times more
likely to work part-time than fathers
following the pandemic the shift to
remote working has made it easier for
some parents to work more flexibly but
not all jobs allow this my work are very
flexible but it's a Juggle and at times
just trying to work out my working
pattern to be able to make it worthwhile
me actually working and financially
contributing to the house I work office
hours my husband does shift work
I'm only three hours off full time so
legally and technically I am a part-time
worker it's the most amount that I can
work that I then don't have to spend all
of it on child care
[Music]
[Laughter]
motherhood penalties vary across the
world
one study looks at motherhood penalties
in six rich countries
it finds that Germany a country where a
lot of women work part-time had the
worst penalty with a 61 drop in long-run
earnings
while Denmark and Sweden had the
smallest but still sizable penalties
that's partly because Scandinavian
countries have longer and better paid
paternity leave
we've seen as a result of that in Sweden
that many more dads are taking time out
of the workplace to care for their
children and as a result of that we've
seen that the gender pay Gap is much
smaller the share of the unpaid labor is
far more equal
over the last 50 or 60 years we've seen
big changes in gender Dynamics and in
countries where we've seen that men have
become more equal partners with women in
raising kids we see that fertility rates
are actually higher than in similar
countries where men aren't contributing
as much to child rearing and housework
take Japan
where women spend far more time on
household chores and child care than
Monday making it much harder for women
to have a career and raise children
despite having some of the most generous
maternity and paternity leave on the
planet
which might explain why Japan has one of
the lowest fertility rates in the world
in nearly all rich industrialized
countries fertility rates have fallen
below 2.1 children per woman the rate
needed to maintain a stable population
and on a macroeconomic level that can
cause problems
so if fertility Falls low enough then
there are potentially not enough workers
in the Next Generation in the long term
it means a change in the labor force how
many workers are available how much
money those workers are paying into
pension programs into taxes most
industrialized countries are pretty far
from that level although there are a few
that have seen really dramatic
reductions in fertility
more open immigration policies could
help but few countries seem willing to
consider them
so falling birth rates can cause
economic disruption should governments
intervene
we want to be careful that governments
aren't doing things that are coercive or
that unduly restrict people's freedom to
have the kind of families and the number
of children that they want but there is
a role for government for supporting
families with children and in many
countries there is certainly a lot more
room for investment from the public
sector
but it's not just about the economics
although that's part of it but it's also
about cultural ideals it's about the
influence of religion it's about the
compatibility of motherhood and careers
and it's about gender Dynamics
choosing to have children is a big
decision governed by Deep Emotions as
well as practicalities more generous
parental leave cheaper child care and
flexibility at work might make the
decision a bit easier
but despite the challenges of Parenthood
those who do choose to have babies
rarely regret it
being a mom has come with its own
struggles and
redefining your own image to yourself
but uh yeah at the end of the day life
is just Fuller with with a new person in
your family it's the hardest thing that
you ever do become an apparent but it's
the most rewarding I've never
experienced such extreme levels of joy
and happiness and Elation and pride as I
have since I've had children
[Music]
for more of our economic and social
analysis click on the link thanks so
much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
foreign